what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch
money right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent polina
pompliano that's it we just go with pp
today
okay don't forget that little buddy is
not sponsored by block five block five
has three products you can buy and sell
crypto on their crypto exchange with no
fees
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest-bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and
take out a us dollar loan to get your
crypto collateral go get a block by
account go to blockfy.com
blockfy.com go do it i promise you'll
like it i'm an investor
i'm a happy user and you will be too
what's up guys i'm sorry that we didn't
record lunch money yesterday i know many
of you were looking forward to it as was
i but we are having wi-fi problems
and by wi-fi problems i mean that we had
no wi-fi
so i went out and i bought that thing
and it's like it you can like bring it
with
it was a whole lot but i saved the day
did i not save the day i
saved it i had to do a debate yesterday
for real vision and i literally did it
sitting in the hallway
with headphones on holding the computer
in front of me it was sad
it was sad i savaged the dude though go
ahead
okay um so
robin hood raised another 2.4 billion
dollars
as the broker app dealt with retail
trading
frenzy this is on top of the 1 billion
you may remember they raised before
so this brings their total to 3.4
billion dollars how did they get the
deal done so quick
well i mean there's three things right
one
oh you see that i started to come all
right i fought it off them uh the first
thing is that uh they raised a billion
dollars last week and they raised
another 2.4 billion over the weekend
some of that is because they need
capital requirements meaning that
basically think of the plumbing the
people that they work with require them
to have certain amounts of deposits to
protect in case something goes wrong
uh and as those requirements got uh
ratcheted up then they had to put more
and more money down they didn't have the
money they had to go raise money
the second thing is that investors uh
are probably seeing
really really aggressive growth right
like uh in the month of january it came
out robin hood had over three million
app downloads
they had six hundred thousand you know
this is actually downloads on friday
because of all the attention and the
price i got a lot of people who didn't
know about robin hood
were more attracted to it or what's the
reasoning here yeah just it's the
streisand effect right yeah sure plenty
of people are upset but at the same time
everyone's talking
about robin hood so when people do they
go i'm going to get in on this and they
go and they download the app and they
want to trade stocks
makes sense to me all right next india
we need some cool music like next
you kind of match the background i just
i have camouflage on actually you didn't
realize that i was going to do that
what today i'm in the uniform and you're
not
india okay india plans to introduce
legislation to ban
cryptocurrencies it plans to introduce
the bill
a bill seeking to prohibit all private
cryptocurrencies in the country during
the budget
session of parliament that began friday
didn't you write about this
i did sorry i was getting a phone call
important stuff you know
uh the whole idea of india banning a
public decentralized protocol
is absurd that's absurd how do you ban
it it's like saying that you're going to
uh shut the internet off that's
essentially what they're saying when
we've seen other countries try to do
this like pakistan
adoption actually went up so they said
hey this is illegal we're going to ban
cryptocurrencies trading in
cryptocurrencies but adoption went up
knocked down
and so thank you i appreciate you
running a marketing campaign india is
about to onboard a bunch of people to
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
so i appreciate it i hope they uh issue
the ban that would be fantastic
i hope i actually don't hope that they
issue the ban i hope they talk about it
and then don't put it in place so it
drives the adoption and also doesn't
cause a headache
but india is going to be one of the most
important uh countries for crypto it's a
big country
uh there's lots and lots of people who
are very techno technically savvy
uh and so i think that this is something
to watch but even if they
go ahead and actually put the ban in
place i just don't think that it's going
to be very effective there's a
difference between enforcement
and the law there is a difference
between yeah they
they're not arresting you guys for uh
jade walking this light is doing me no
favors today okay
melvin capital the hedge fund because uh
that's because you're not tan like me
you're not tan you're just sitting in
the better light
melvin capital the hedge fund that bet
against
gamestop lost more than 50 percent in
january
wow how many billions is that
they had 13 billion so yeah they lost
like
six and a half to seven billion uh i
mean
if you take risk in the market and
you're wrong
you should lose money and they did no
melvin's assets under management now
stand up more than eight billion
including the emergency funding down
from roughly 12.5 billion at the
beginning of the year yeah so they lost
six and a half billion dollars
and then they got another 2.75 billion
put in by citadel
and 0.72 wow so okay so it's interesting
he had a conversation with kevin o'leary
last night on clubhouse and i learned a
lot personally
but the one thing that stood out to me
is kevin o'leary being like
at first i thought these like mobs of
people were just like really dumb but he
was like i went on reddit
i started reading these are very
sophisticated young people
like just because you know
the they're kind of being painted it's
like the mob and like herds of
uninformed dumb money it's not dumb
money
it's actually very smart money of course
i mean look
if you read the post that outlines the
short squeeze before it happened
that that's research that would be at a
uh kind of sophisticated wall street
hedge fund like that was a
very very thoughtful very very accurate
well-researched piece
and by the way they were right and they
short squeezed the hell now they didn't
do it alone there's other institutions
that kind of jumped in when they saw the
momentum going
um but there there's absolutely no doubt
about it that they called their shot
they were like babe ruth they got up to
the plate
pointed to center field pitch came down
the middle of the plate
and they hit a home run and good for
them they should profit from it now just
be careful don't go buy
gamestop and think that you're going to
get rich if you want to buy gamestop for
entertainment purposes you're going to
likely lose your money because it's
going to keep falling because the
company's not worth 50 billion dollars
but
if you want to do it for entertainment
purposes knock yourself out just don't
think that you're going to uh
go make a ton of cash okay so
speaking of clubhouse clubhouse the
audio only social app
is now looking at ways to monetize the
platform for its creators so it's gonna
create a model where let's say i'm the
moderator and you're a participant
in the room the audience members
can tip or you know pay
me or him if they're enjoying the
conversation et cetera it's kind of
similar to a patreon model
it's unclear how much of a cut clubhouse
will get
but what do we think about this idea for
monetization
yeah i think this is interesting um my
guess is that it's not as binary as
everyone wants it to be right it's like
the users are still gonna find ways to
make money and whether that's through
sponsorship
tipping uh subscriptions you know
there's a whole bunch of different
things that you could do
but what i do think is really important
is uh
that the clubhouse team is thinking
differently about monetization
um but i gotta say that the experience
on the application
uh just you just don't get it anywhere
else it really really is
uh pretty valuable um and so i think
that uh it's only gonna continue to grow
remember when people and i i told you it
wouldn't happen but remember when people
thought that twitter audio was gonna be
like the next hot thing
that did not take off fyi
do you listen to audio on twitter just
because i don't use it doesn't mean it's
not popular
nobody uses it i bet you more people use
twitter audio than clubhouse right now
no way
yeah well we'll discuss and debate this
later but
my my point is only because the user
base is
my my other um my other
knit to pick with this is that um
is that uh i don't think
that if they do tipping on clubhouse i
don't think it'll be significant
for a lot of these people because like
what i have like
1800 followers on on um clubhouse did
you just flex them
[Music]
whatever compare that to anybody else
who already has
who already is a public figure has big
followings elsewhere
i just think that like it's a volume
game i might be able to attract
30 people at most in my room what are
they gonna tip me like a dollar
at most if everybody tips i get thirty
dollars
i i just i think what who's tipping a
dollar
oh is it gonna be less it's gonna be
more you think
somebody's gonna be like i enjoyed this
conversation so much i'm gonna give you
ten dollars nobody's giving me ten
dollars
yes why not who is giving that is absurd
for ten dollars you can get netflix
so what are you learning on netflix you
might learn something
how much money do you think would have
been tipped to the room
for the people who brought elon musk on
do you think they would have got a
dollar
no no i think they but that was my point
because the people with the massive
followings are able to attract
such a large num such a large number of
people
they are probably the ones that would
benefit the most versus the smaller
people
who are having great conversations but
nobody's coming
of course if you don't build an audience
you don't get rewarded yeah but like
does kevin will you need an extra
hundred dollars i don't know i i don't
think so but
are we gonna be in a socialist society
where we should make it all equal no
it's a free market if you get people
there they want to pay you that you
should take all the money but i'm saying
it's benefiting a certain type of
demographic
i disagree i think that i think that
there's a lot of people who have
no audience anywhere else that now are
building an audience on
i mean that's possible josh constantine
has like
900 000 followers i love josh
but josh ain't got 900 000 followers on
twitter
right okay um so he so you're able to
build different people will build
that's fair that's fair i'm just you
know talking about my personal
experience
elon musk speaking of elon says his
startup neural link has wired up a
monkey
to play video games using its mind so
again neuralink is the brain machine
interface company that he has i find it
fascinating and now neuralink has put a
computer chip
into the monkey's skull and use tiny
wires
to connect it to its brain it's not an
unhappy monkey that's my favorite part
because he says the monkey's not unhappy
wait why would he say that
because the monkey's not unhappy the
monkey's having a blast he's playing
video games
oh you can't even see where the neural
implant was put in except that he's got
a slight light a slight
like dark mohawk i don't know what that
means okay
he's got a little mohawk they have a
little mohawk wearing monkey playing
video games
that monkey is living his best i'm less
interested in the commercial
and consumer and like fun type of
application
i'm interested in the medical
implications of something like
this all right i want us to augment our
brains with
if i had google up here i wouldn't have
to read the internet i could just be
googling all the time and i would
never i'll be so mad at you okay
it's ask lunch money time competiting
right now
i'm computating right now hashtag ask
ellen ready
yes put hashtag ask ellen in the
comments so i can see your question
um chris fettner asks how do you think
this gamestop situation
ends do you think it is inevitable they
all move into bitcoin to escape
the rigged system well personally i
think that bitcoin has
wildly profited off of this go on i
don't think that
it's a binary game i don't think you get
everyone to do anything go one direction
or the other some people will go
to bitcoin and cryptocurrency some will
stay and trade stocks
others will say the system is rigged and
i'm gonna go
hole up in a closet somewhere and just
hold onto my gold bars like people are
going to go in all different directions
but it's very clear that this
uh was kind of a rallying cry for the
internet uh and it wouldn't surprise me
if
if it continues um and what you
basically did was you woke up a
generation
they got reminded whether the actual
events
support this or not they just got
reminded the system does not work for a
lot of people
uh and people are gonna go look for
solutions now all these different
companies
uh industries are gonna basically
compete to try to get those people to
come
and spend time with them cool james
carson
what's going to stop these hedge fund
cats i love that
and macro dudes from pulling all their
money out of it going when the price
climbs thank you well if they sell their
bitcoin they're selling it to somebody
else so for every seller there's a buyer
uh and so i think that um it is unlikely
that uh the hedge funds really matter
it's more so the large financial
institutions right the biggest
beneficiary from the gamestop chaos last
week the biggest profiter was fidelity
and it's just because they're so big
they gotta own
airplay everything uh and so i think
that that's a similar situation here
where
uh basically all these large financial
institutions uh a bunch of them are
gonna own bitcoin
and so those are the ones that are
unlikely to sell
they're not traders um and so they'll
provide some sort of floor for the asset
levi carr what is the best question
you've ever been asked
and why will you marry me is the best
question ever
okay i knew she was gonna say that
kidding me i know some questions i have
a question
um the best question i've been asked
asked
is how do you define success and so
once i heard that i started asking it um
because
i think it tells you a lot about a
person based on how they
define the word success when i say that
the profile studies the most successful
people in companies a lot of people
are like oh i don't like that and you
don't like that because
you're uh you're kind of uh
taught to think that success is what
society deems as successful
when i left fortune people were like oh
but why do you why would you leave
fortune you were so successful
but if it if it doesn't feel like
success to you
it isn't success at all
my favorite question is do you think
aliens have pets
that's mine do you think so yeah of
course
i mean there's definitely a
multi-species uh
what does an alien dog look like a
smaller alien
what does a dog look like just a
four-legged smaller human
it's not a human it's a wholly different
species listen
humans only really do four things okay
uh kids show they pee they poop
they talk and they have fun that's it
that's basically it
they pee they poop they communicate and
they have fun
that's part of the peeing and pooping
that's when your body's
used again part of the pooping i'm
telling you like it's all it's just all
four things
anything any four things that you want
you can put in those categories
part of the communication that you're
gonna
so that's what the aliens do they pee
they poop
they communicate and they have fun i'm
glad you guys got a great history lesson
today in biology unless it's like
biology and history
and in case you're new here in case
you're new here i'm going to do one
piece of information then i'll let you
guys all go but
in case you didn't know when astronauts
go to space they gotta pee they gotta
poop they gotta communicate and they
gotta have fun
when they pee and they poop they take
the p and they put it out into space
they literally
they're just polluting space with the
pea out of the little aircraft
but the poop the poop ain't gonna be
floating around they're gonna
put the poop and then bring it back down
to earth and then they dispose of it so
in case you ever wondered when the
astronauts got to go to the bathroom the
p
stays in space and the poop comes back
to earth and that's it for lunch money i
hope you guys have a great day
don't ever tell anyone that i didn't
teach you something important
see ya bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to 8.6 interest on an
interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends